[Musique]
voilà
je m'amuse bien je suis là pour garder
le kiosque de julie et moi là
tout s'est bien passé
à merveille calme plat
je ramasse des feuilles de chou fleur
des vieux papiers des bastides met par
terre mais oui c'est très fun qu'elle
s'est traîné tension
si les enfants sont venus jeter tout ça
il ne les mettrait par terre je crois
qu'il faudrait des poubelles à
différents endroits du jardin que l' on
viderait chaque soir c'est une très
bonne idée et puis on instituerait un
tour de rôle pour que ça soit pas
toujours aux mêmes de les libérer alors
moins 10 pour moi le mardi le mercredi
le zoo jeudi mademoiselle futile et c
est moi quand j'ai une idée je serai
dispensés au dessus tout produit tout
dedans et pourquoi à
ton tour comme tout le monde moi je
pense que tout le monde sera d'accord il
suffire à expliquer à chacun oui mais il
faudrait d'abord parlé au président de
la fieec lauzon c'est à dire à un homme
qui a raison je lui téléphone tout de
suite
allé aux messieurs du snob bonjour
monsieur dit stop je ne vous dérange pas
ah bon et bien voilà
leona françois et moi on avoir une idée
ça vous a été enfin c'est très aimable à
vous
je vais vous expliquer en deux mots
en soit je ne comprends pas les licences
en nous en mettant ce tout petit
on a vraiment partout merci bonjour tout
le monde oh oh oh pour sûr je suis
puisse
regarder ce que j'ai apporté ce sont des
colis d'un genre particulier
et avec des poignées 1 à la facteur vous
prendrez bien un délit c'est pas drôle
mademoiselle julie
d'autant que je vais pas fini de tourner
un bon cadeau vecteur g73 colis et à
livrer il n'y a marqué que l'île aux
enfants qu'on n'a pas marqué nom du
destinataire commun cela bah oui alors
il faut que j'aille je suis chaque
habitant de l'île le recteur ce ne sera
pas la peine car c'est trois colis sont
tous les habitants de l'île aux assauts
et c'est monsieur du snob qui les a
commandées mais vous n arrivez pas ce
que ces boues balles sont faites pour le
jardin voilà au aux poursuites c'est une
bonne nouvelle sans facteur vous nous
aider à les déballer s'il vous plaît
laissez ensuite au travail voilà j'avais
dix jours merci merci julie merci
la
voilà opération terminée un facteur cela
mérite bien un petit bobo tu permets
jolie bien servir merci julie
merci léonard bon
le papier
c'est moi qui ai jeté ce moment quelque
chose a dit qu'ils voulaient voir ce
soir
bon maintenant je vais continuer ma
tournée et annoncer cette bonne nouvelle
à tous les habitants un bon facteur pour
fêter ça voulait pas me faire un petit
plaisir moi je lis tout ce que vous
voudrez
sauter moi votre chanson oh mais vous
savez très bien que c'est à moi que ça
fait plaisir
j'aurais pu être plombier zingueur
meunier masson géographe
j'aurais dû même être chaud entre
j'aurais pu être petit bassin officer
coo et calandra
mais j'ai choisi d'être procter
quand je suis le roi seul dans ton grave
je suis l'ami des jolis mots
amoureux des phrases et ses vidéos
je les emporte sur mon
seule la branche ont
rôdé
j'aurais pu être plombier zingueur
meunier façon ou géographe
j'aurais pu même être chanteur
aurait pu être cultivateurs comprise ou
mécanographe mais j'ai choisi d'être un
facteur
car je suis le roi de l'orthographe
j'aime les lettres oui
les écritures guézé charmante quand leur
taux grave faire respecter cela
m'enchante
j'aurais pu être plombier zingueur
meunier maçon ou géographe
j'aurais pu même être un chanteur
j'aurais pu être il tivat heures confie
ce fou mécano bras ouais j'ai choisi
d'être
je suis le roi de leurs programmes
dès que commence ce matin
tout le long du chemin que je chante
les gens jettent mon arrivée cela mon
jean
[Applaudissements]
j'aurais plus être pompier ailleurs
veniez masson rouge et au g
j'aurais pu même être un chanteur
j'aurais pu être cultivateurs confiseurs
fou mégalomane
mais j'ai choisi d'être pas de fer forgé
mais j'ai choisi d'être un patin
[Musique]
où
tout est impeccable
c'est casimir qui vient de nettoyer le
jardin ils vous d'elle oui c'était son
tour et pour bien montrer qu'il les a
vidé il les a retourné c'est formidable
mais c'est pas ça le jardin d'un
formidable ça et moi je vais pouvoir
étudier dias tranquillement
où je suis fan et
et bien dire qu'il me reste encore la
moitié de ma commande aller chercher bon
eh bien je vais commencer à déballer ses
cartons et ensuite j'irai chercher le
reste
après tout je vais faire le contraire
tuez les courges et la
gelée déballerai je vais chercher tout
de suite le reste du jury auourd'hui
ainsi chercher le reste de ma commande
aubin juillet n'est pas taxée à écoute
françois c'est trop gentil écoute si tu
veux me rendre service commence à
déballer ses cartons j'en viens tout de
suite avec plaisir
france on nous collait c'est la nouvelle
mademoiselle futé casimir et monsieur du
snop sont allés faire une partie de
pêche vraiment de la chance bon moi
j'aimerais bien pouvoir m'amuser ainsi
mais j'ai pas le temps vous fais
remarquer que casimir avant de partir a
parfaitement fait son travail oui les
poubelles sont vides et nettoyé et rangé
au pour sûr vous avez raison françois
demain c'est mon tour je vais me
surpasser
bonjour les bills bonjour mademoiselle
je
peux vous aider et votre tour et
réacteurs à eau ma tournée en fait je
peux bien prendre un petit peu de temps
pour aider mademoiselle julie vraiment
faim si si écoutez si vous voulez mais d
aller me chercher une poubelle comme ça
je mettrai mes emballages vivent dedans
[Musique]